now this is a michael bay film and
you're a woman so just touch your boobs
come on there you go yeah both hands
both hands there you go oh yeah oh yeah
bail all of that all right now now
you're running away robots are after you
look scared good no optimus prime just
died you're sad but he came back now
he's dead again but he came back this
time he's really dead he came back next
okay you're gonna try a Shia LaBeouf's
part go ahead say something okay you
have potential no it's good you're gonna
be the sassy best friend okay you're
gonna be the guy that everyone looks and
it's like oh he's crazy he's goofy but
now Optimus Prime just died but he came
back and you're goofy about it next Oh
God an hour woman okay I already had the
other one touch her breath so let's see
um do you have a car you can drape
yourself over what you showed up to a
Michael Bay audition you didn't bring a
car to drape yourself over what the very
least tell me you have a motorcycle to
pull out your pocket you can drape
yourself over that next okay I just get
a feeling you're gonna be the bad guy
you're the bad guy that the woman falls
in love with it doesn't believe shy of
both because he's an idiot and a dimwit
Jim wait that's right you look snobby
snobby er snobby r think Brad Jones very
good oh he would do that he would
definitely do that yeah now say Megatron
I trust you even though you were called
a Decepticon Megatron I trust you even
know you were called a Decepticon let's
go but can you make your voice even more
raspy Megatron I trust you more raspy
drawing I draw more raspy Megatron much
next wow you can actually be an Autobot
I'm gonna call you truck driver BOTS cuz
you look like a truck driver okay you're
you're one of the Autobots Optimus Prime
is in danger Optimus I've come to save
you Oh next okay you're gonna be one of
the women running away from all the
robots are trying to get you so look up
you're scared it's more scared more
scared start laying those arms around
that's right now we run back and forth
back and forth but suddenly you realize
you're a woman at a michael bay film and
you see your boobs that makes you happy
next okay i'm gonna try something a
little different on this one you're a
woman in a michael bay film you see your
breasts they look good you like touching
them for no reason you know what i think
it gotta be the female lead okay I'm not
gonna lie you kinda look like my agent
okay so i think we can also do i don't
know why i want i have this urge to have
you review ET porn you know what that's
what you're gonna review transformers
porn it'll be a spin-off a lot of people
say it's what the movies are anyway but
we're gonna go for it all right try
reviewing transformers porn so today
we're going to talk about a little thing
I like to call transformers porn that's
good and what do they what do the
transformers change in do they change
into a dildo or something Giants pei you
got the job next